pour moi c'est l'afrique ça représente
le chemin des possibles ça représente
une force ça représente aussi
l'espoir ça représente le futur pour moi
l'afrique c'est le futur
[Musique]
alors je me présente je m'appelle iso et
je suis et j'ai ri l'ol
le message que j'aimerais faire passer à
la génération sur un message d'espoir et
d'inclusivité
l'avenir de la mode pour moi c'est la
diversité
ma le corps c'est quand même c'est un
grand point d'interrogation pour moi
c'est ainsi aussi une grande part
d'ombré et de tristesse et c'est aussi
ma force aujourd'hui parce que je suis
là je suis gérer le réel parce que
parce que je suis celle que je suis
aujourd'hui donc j'espère que ça va
inspirer la nouvelle génération j'espère
que ça va donner de l'espoir en tout cas
ces générations
fusionnelle
l'afrique ça représente
beaucoup de choses ça représente
premièrement le chemin des possibles ça
représente une force ça représente aussi
l'espoir ça représente le futur pour moi
l'afrique c'est le futur et je trouve
qu'il ya eu un mépris en fait
général par rapport à ceux à ce
continent qui a une ressource
incroyable et qui est pour moi un peu
trop exploité et
par des personnes qui ne devraient pas
l'exploiter et
là j'ai l'impression qu'on s'y moment où
depuis genre là depuis quelques années
entre la côte d'ivoire le sénégal le
ghana le nigeria genre le cameroun tous
et puis là en fait sont en train de
d'exploser en fait aussi bien
même même au niveau de l'industrie
musicale en amérique faut voir le
nigeria gens les bernabei les highways
par genre les ladipo fin les rema avec
qui j'ai collaboré dernièrement par
genre
pour moi ça représente vraiment le futur
et
l'avenir sera juste merveilleux pour
l'afrique non mais un général